yeah going back to scott's question are
there beef between
isn't it yeah because i see that
competitions you know like when you're a
street and everybody's just kind of
standing there while the one guy skates
but like
behind the scenes are you guys like now
[ __ ] you well yeah i think the answer to
your question about is there beef
between skateboard companies
yes and not only that but there's like
secret
like you know like top big stars
defecting from their companies to go
start other companies and then like
the nobody knows about it until it
actually happens and there's all this
backstabbing and betrayal and like
what do you mean like they start a
company while they're still with another
company and then as soon as they
get their company started they're like
it's like getting another girlfriend
before you break up with the girlfriend
you've got
yeah yeah the first plan b ad
was five of these writers are gonna be
leaving their current sponsors to start
a new company
and we had the list of all the top pros
on this ad
so it was like all of the all the
companies were going like oh [ __ ]
who's going to be like they didn't know
i mean but if you look at our ad it's
like
it's like everybody hawk i mean you name
it like you know all the top guys in
that time
we're on this list that we're going to
be potentially leaving their current
sponsor to start plan b
so for like until the next ad dropped
which is like the next month where we
had
the team list you know the team riders
actually you know on that ad
for about a month you know people were
tripping like whoa who's like what's
happening here who's who's going to be
leaving who you know like that's so
great
i mean what about like fights and stuff
were there any other physical stuff
going down behind the scenes or was it
like at parties when you ran into each
other look at this guy's face he's
smiling about something
i mean i just i'm just thinking
skateboarders are
you know like and and in skateboard
culture is pretty [ __ ] cool man to be
honest like
despite how much you know like hey i
want to [ __ ] win this contest or i
want to do better
you know i think you know there's been a
couple you know i think people that have
beef
but not like you would think i think for
the most part for how rebellious
skateboarding has been over the years
and
you know it being kind of an outcast you
know industry or whatever or society
it's i think for the most part a lot of
respect and you know amongst each other
to be honest you know so
i i've you know i haven't seen too much
to be
on that level it's more than like
politics within
business culture yeah got it but that
doesn't equal this it's just more of
like
that guy just one up me with that
strategy okay how do we fire back
you know clever with cleverness and
effectiveness
it's like anything else there's more
fist fights over [ __ ]
you humped my girl [ __ ] pop okay okay
got it
it's not like a [ __ ] tribalism like
i'm part of this crew like you're
[ __ ] i mean
there is some of that but it's like it's
business you know
it's business and and yeah that's crazy
i've never heard about the ad
where it's like there's this new company
plan b and
we're gonna take five of these
five of these top pros are gonna be
leaving their current sponsors to start
a new brand
wow yeah dude